was bei uns
unvorstellbar absurd klingt ist in 19
us-bundesstaaten tatsächlich realität
lehrer und lehrerinnen dürfen ihre
schüler schlagen und jetzt jetzt liegt
der nächste bezirk nach in den usa er
führt eine schule in missouri und das
auch noch ein wirklich auf wunsch der
eltern wie der körperliche züchtigung
ein also ab sofort ist es dort erlaubt
die schüler mit einem panel zu schlagen
eine ohrfeige vom lehrer wenn man den
unterricht stört schläge auf den hof als
man die hausaufgaben vergessen hat das
wie ein relikt aus vorkriegszeiten wirkt
ist nun wieder erschreckende realität
zumindest in einer schule in den usa
genauer gesagt in missouri
an unserer schule gab es besorgnis über
die disziplin der schüler und so haben
wir reagiert indem wir verschiedene
strategien umgesetzt haben körperliche
bestrafung ist eine davon es ist etwas
von dem wir nicht erwarten dass wir es
häufig verwenden wir machen das nur mit
einer zustimmung der eltern der vife
gegen kinder das steht jetzt also wieder
auf dem stundenplan der schülerinnen und
schüler in kessel eltern und schüler
wurden nun über diese neue richtlinie
der
disziplinierungsmaßnahmen informiert
körperliche züchtigung was unter
erwachsenen als straftat gilt und für
gewöhnlich mit einer anzeige und deren
folgen endet wird jetzt ganz frei gegen
kinder angewendet der blanke hohn denn
jede form der gewaltanwendung
hinterlässt schaden gerade bei kindern
kinder zu schlagen ist in deutschland
seit dem jahr 2000 verboten in missouri
jetzt schon wieder alltag oberschulrat
marie johnson kann dabei gut grinsen ihn
erwarten ja keine schläge
unfassbar prügelstrafe sondern legte aus
alten grauen zeiten und jetzt dort
wieder erlaubt wer mit ihnen darüber
gesprochen mit unseren zuschauerinnen
und zuschauern wie finden sie das
prügelstrafe
ist das noch so für dich vorstellbar
also ich finde die pädagogik hat zutage
sollte sich von bestrafungen eigentlich
fern halten haben wir ziemlich
offensichtlich dass man das nicht machen
sollte aber ja ich wusste gar nicht
davon sind wir darüber nicht jung von
hinaus also wieso auch schon weiter
entwickelt seien nicht mehr zu prügeln
also das herz jugendlicher bayerischen
gegen das wirkliche leben ist
sozusagen ein step back places über
kammern erreicht man auch nicht weil die
kinder die einzige sache dass sie
brachen ist lieber mit lieber sie können
alles verstehen da ist der ansatz aus
den usa geht und die komplett verkehrte
richtung was würdest du dir stattdessen
noch mehr wünschen also in deutschland
und den usa naja also mehr dass jeder
einzelne in seinen talenten gefördert
wird weniger druck weniger auf leistung
für mich das auf jeden fall einfach so
ein bisschen ein zeichen dass man also
als europäer und als europäische
gemeinschaft gucken sollte das uns nicht
das genauso ergeht usa entwickelt sich
gerade auch eher zurück als nach vorne
man sieht ja dass ich jetzt mit
overweight was da geschehen ist und so
also da kann man nicht mal nach da
gucken um zu sehen was fortschritt ist
sondern eher zu gucken was wir bald
arbeiten
[Musik]